qu'est-ce que vous voyez
votre fille
le parc j'ai eu un moment d'inattention
je suis une seconde
[Musique]
c'est le boulot je suis prêt à prendre
le service à pamment vous vous sentez
prêt je crois que c'est la seule chose
qui me fait tenir
c'est quoi cet appel là je voudrais
signaler un braquage de banque parce que
vous voyez ce type sur le banc vous
auriez du feu il prépare quelque chose
il fait très chaud aujourd'hui
une vraie fournaise il fait chaud
une vraie fournaise
il y a un coffre c'est la cible le
numéro 23
[Musique]
où elle est
c'est que la faux venait de vous pour le
braquage
qui êtes-vous qu'est-ce qui peut pousser
de parfaits inconnus à commettre un
braquage de haut voilà est-ce que vous
connaissez un peu le principe de
l'hypnose l'hypnose
l'hypnose donne la possibilité
d'influencer le cerveau un bruit
une fois du feu un regard
c'est comme ça qu'il s'y prennent pour
vous faire croire à une version du monde
qui n'existe pas
je dois tout savoir
pourquoi moi pourquoi ma fille
vous ne savez pas à qui vous avez
affaire
[Musique]
est-ce que vous voyez n'est pas réel
reculez
tout ce que vous faites
est parfaitement normal